ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta là la
musique c'est 80 % des effectifs du
conservatoire de tours
pour les élèves admis cette discipline
se décline en instrumental solfège et
pratique collective
vingt-huit jeunes composent cet
orchestre à cordes qui illustre ce
travail musical collectif un cours
d'orchestre qui nécessite une pédagogie
adaptée au rythme scolaire vous fait un
court de fonds pour apprendre à jouer à
28 personnes ensemble mais de façon
hebdomadaire donc on a un programme qui
normalement est donnée à la fin d'un
trimestre est dans une situation
ordinaire
on se prépare une semaine avant voire
quinze jours avant et puis après on
appelle tous les jours et ça va être
plus en plus vite
et là il faut faire un travail de fond
et la foire un travail de production
artistique pour que tout le monde ait
compris et tout le monde est encore la
motivation en décembre de jouer les
morceaux qu'on a préparé des lois de 7,1
cours d'orchestre du mercredi après-midi
qui offre souvent aux élèves un premier
engagement collectif
ce qui est important c'est aussi d'être
tous ensemble parce qu'on peut pas le
faire tous ensemble chez nous où c'est
ça qui est bien là on peut vraiment
partager les difficultés comme les bons
côtés de
de bad leur qu'istres des morceaux et on
voit tout une progression au fil de
l'année des morceaux et c'est vraiment
joli et à la fin les 1200 musiciens
admis au conservatoire de tours de
l'éveil aux professionnels s'inscrivent
forcément dans une démarche de pratique
à plusieurs qu'on essaie que de 15 ans
font les préparer la suite et la suite
c'est la pratique collective donc dans
les orchestres c'est le fait de jouer
avec sa soeur comme ce qu'on vient de
devoir c'est le fait de constituer un
petit groupe c'est le fait de porter sa
propre pratique et ça ça passe pour le
collectif c'est très rare qu'on me suis
un amateur joue tout seul entre
parenthèses pas très rigolo de jouets
sont au delà des cursus diplômant cette
volonté de pratiques collectives s'étend
aussi aux amateurs et aux étudiants qui
fréquentent le conservatoire
[Musique]